so we're getting to the end of 2017 one
of the things we like to do is look at
some of the most watched new videos of
the year and I think there's no doubt
you won't be surprised once we start
showing these to you that 2017 was
certainly the year of Trump I didn't
vote for the guy as you know but Donald
Trump no doubt and the constant scandals
of this administration have been good
for programs like the david pakman show
there's absolutely no denying it and to
be clear these are the most watched new
videos of 2017 we have classics from
2016 15 14 13 really all the way back to
the beginning of our YouTube channel
that continued to be in the most watched
videos every single year but these are
the most watched videos that were
created in 2017 starting with are we
going in reverse order reversion no
reverse order yet we should build up to
the number one so I'd like to start with
number 10
Trump forgets his wife is next to him
Melania really wanted to be with us just
under five hundred thousand views the
ninth most-watched new video Trump
implodes during easiest interview in
history also close to five hundred
thousand views number eight
Trump is Navy SEAL shut down by Anna
Navarro on live TV over five hundred and
fifty thousand views I like this one
this was a really good shutdown by
Republican Anna Navarro number seven
most-watched new video of 2017 Trump
pretended to speak Japanese during the
Prime Minister's visit this was an
instant classic when it happened five
hundred and eighty four thousand views
during the year number six
Kellyanne Conway implodes on fake news
CN n five hundred and eighty six
thousand views a doozy of an interview I
don't remember this one exactly because
there have been so many I know in Conway
implosion
it's like which one of Kellyanne
Conway's embarrassing appearances was
this the number five most watched new
video of the year racist woman harasses
Muslim shopper and Trader Joe's over 1
million views yes for the fifth mouth
will almost fifth most-watched new video
included my avocado expose that's right
pat pointing to the fact that the woman
had only four avocados in her shopping
cart and that that is very suspicious
why would you even need a cart if all
you're buying is a bag of avocados
and what exactly was she gonna do with
those one of your incisive I think
comments on a video clip that we played
during the year two and far between but
number four most-watched new video of
the year uh-oh does Donald Trump know
how to read 1.1 million views and a
topic of much concern to the audience
over the year the number three most
watched video of the year is Trump
suffering from dementia 1.2 million
views during the year the number two
most watched video of the year on
YouTube Wow Trump fails basic literacy
test nearly 2 million views as we have
talked about the Trump reading thing
yeah making an impression on people
during the year and the number one most
watched new video of 2017 on the David
Pakman show YouTube channel you can see
the moment when Trump crushes Melania
Seoul over three million views on
YouTube
this one had millions of views on
Facebook as well super viral and it was
a very very big year on the David Pakman
show YouTube channel surpassing the
400,000 subscriber mark I'm looking
forward to at this rate we'll hit 500k
during 2018 right for 2017 we've
surpassed 300,000 and and for how
subscribers so I'm shooting for 600,000
in 2018 yeah that's I actually haven't
looked at where we are where we are
targeting but the top 10 most viewed new
videos of 2017 there they are we will
talk to you in the new year